we blew it yeah there it is on YouTube
yeah I know this will just started all
right there it is on YouTube let's do it
what about Facebook
[Music]
what's up guys what's up welcome welcome
we have not been last ten minutes we've
been basically setting things up you
think people came yeah mmm yeah that's
terrible that yeah this is see we do
this [ __ ] called Alan or is it maybe we
did it
maybe you told me when did you tell me
we've been doing this a ma now we don't
know we did this cold
so basically cold um in relation to
prepper II like we just don't know
anything you know that's the thing we
just don't know anything yet that's our
problem
good well it's good that we're live on
YouTube but Facebook I seriously think
they're making us wait 10 minutes so
well
five more minutes until the next I did
get an error message when I stream this
second time so all right let's at least
let's at least go what's at least go to
youtube let me at least comment back to
Rebekah and tell her that we're on
dead air interesting question is what I
said I gave her the link I've given
people the link okay so what's the
question again the question is thoughts
on Demi Lovato's overdose okay so first
of all is Demi Lovato dead I'm sorry for
my ignorance no no she's not dead
overdose she had an overdose yeah she
had an overdose but she's not dead and
it says I know some there was seemed
like there was overdose was meth okay I
have no idea I just you know what I can
say about this that I think might be
relatable oh we have a comment from
Joplin Steele thanks for commenting
Joplin we appreciate it
do you want let me answer you can you
zoom in on the yeah I will an answer
Rebecca's question yeah
just answering Rebecca I can zoom in for
some reason that's the best I can do
Rebecca just to answer your question my
thoughts on on on that is that mental
health is seriously crazy and that
there's a lot of it's a very difficult
topic and that it's crazy that some
certain things like Fame and wealth can
get to people and cause them to have
mental lapses and so does poor being
very poor and being not loved in your
community and all this other kind of
stuff leads to mental there's it's a
very strange world even people that work
9:00 to 5:00 have mental Oh nobody's
loved me more than cocaine nobody's
loved me more than my drugs nobody's
loved me more than my Chinese food my
Chinese food loves me and I love my I
love my disco shoes did you see my disco
shoes alright we got a question from
Joplin Steele what do you know about Q
FB is on that means Facebook is on okay
oh is it
Oh Facebook is on we're streaming on
Facebook that's what he said all right
let's check it out let's check it out
let's check it out
Oh B let me get out of here okay let me
go somewhere else go ahead what did you
are you gonna answer that woman's
question yeah yeah I was just trying to
figure out where the where the live
stream is but he said what do you know
about question Facebook is on I don't
know what that means
oh here it is going live in 49 48 this
is for that 416 thing okay oh there it
is right 43 let's see if it does it
let's see if it doesn't I hope it does
it I told you 39 seconds I told you it's
some BS you know see this is gonna say
go live and I'm gonna be able to click
it I bet okay we'll see I don't know
this person
Joplin's said Facebook is on I don't I
don't have the notification or do I the
simulations gathered a live video to
begin in one minute people following
your event have been notified this is
the worst day first that's all right
go to live in a second seven yeah I
don't think we're gonna go I don't think
because of the encoder we'll see going
live in zero admin only
the live video should start soon edit
your details okay and let's make sure we
still have the right stream key hi I
gotta get me get out of here okay oh my
god edit edit edit edit you know the
view that you're fullscreen and now let
me see my credentials 297 476 yeah it's
weird okay
yeah there was an issue with the with
the we shouldn't have tested or whatever
let's just go to Facebook we blew it we
blew it man
are you afraid of death from Schindler
death would y'all know about Schindler
thinks the question we all gonna die
I'll answer the question now you know
you take too long
are you afraid of death that's a yes or
no question Allen are you afraid of
death Allen
he asked answer the question I think
death might be
the end of our physical body but it
might not be the end of what goes past
that so why do you say it with doubt it
might be why do you why can't you just
why do you why don't you just Schindler
has asked another question how much do
you want to live forever on a scale of
one to ten it's a good good question
should we do great don't we have Aubrey
de Grey coming up at the the battery
yeah we're gonna talk with him dr.
Aubrey de Grey he's working with the
Sens foundation they working on
extending life Aubrey de Grey believes
that aging is a disease and not part of
just the natural cycle of life and he
wants to extend our lives and my
question is for whoo-whoo-whoo what for
the rulers and the oppressed it's lovely
so shouldn't there to answer your
question how much do you want to live
forever on a scale of one to ten zero
you know part of me is quite interested
in living a very long time because it's
really awesome to think about observing
the evolution of humanity and I think
that is most exciting for me about it
but part of me also wants to see what
death is like and what and what that and
what that process is like you know you
can I it is this your show or my show I
mean I don't want it I don't want to
steal the are no go ahead we don't know
we don't have another question you you
mentioned a life extension possibly
being it would give us a chance to
observe the evolutionary process is that
what you you would said yeah we're
extending life would do that well let's
let's let's let's ponder this people
live their life anyway like they're
going to live forever okay that's how
they live their life for whatever reason
people
think people live their life like
they're never gonna die and they're
gonna live forever and they and they and
they and they and they they conduct
themselves accordingly which is really
not good for the evolutionary process I
feel that if we understand that these
bodies are gonna die there's only a
certain amount of time that you have if
anything you know maximum maybe 110 you
know and but at any given moment you
know you could that you could die any
day and that's what people feel to
realize and prevents them for actually
from actually living to the fullest you
know if you think you're gonna live
forever you're not you're certainly not
gonna live your life to the fullest but
if you know that you're dying to
tomorrow dying tomorrow I'm sure
life is gonna change for you you're
gonna conduct yourself accordingly so my
answer on the life extension thing just
looking at how people conduct themselves
as if they are gonna live forever and oh
no I'm waiting for people to die we're
waiting for people to die Alan there's
people among us that just seem just to
never die and their ideas and their
power prevent us from moving forward
there's people calling shots that I
cannot wait till they die because
they're not gonna change they're gonna
go out believing the same [ __ ] that
they concluded two years ago and and
that's what we have to deal with and
these people are calling shots in life
making decisions on our behalf
mine and yours so I'm not convinced I'm
looking i we've you've done work with
Aubrey de Grey what three times already
you've sat down with him three times and
we're gonna do sit down again good I'm
good he has the he has the opportunity
to convince me that it's a good thing to
extend our life beyond the natural life
cycle for the human being which is about
a hundred
years old there is okay there is
biblical scripture you know that
suggested what Moses was three hundred
years old or or whatever but you know
that's a biblical scripture and not
quite you know it could be just a
fictitious Blair is probably part of
what you said that's is there any other
questions really important no there's no
other questions yet that there's a yeah
there's something about people that are
like megalomaniacs that are obsessed
with the greed and power and corruption
and money and stuff and that some people
that are just very very ignorant it's
difficult to teach people these things
to not be ignorant or not be greedy and
megalomaniac so yeah they're probably
funding the Sens foundation these people
that we're talking about I think there's
a lot of good people that are also that
we'd love to live yes without a doubt
Allen there are good people wonderful
lovely fantabulous people in this world
that I would just I would not really
another question and the I do think
there are people that should live I
think there are good a lot about our
funding sons and there are good people
that should live long and observe and
guide civilization and retain yeah okay
home you said capacity of a
thirteen-year-old throughout life
next question Schindler thanks for
asking the next question have you ever
saved a human life
that's good question how come your
questions aren't showing up where are
you seeing your questions just in the
chat and the YouTube child how come the
chat isn't showing up on my feed it's
weird maybe we can still play around
with Facebook and try and get that to
work oh I see it I'm sorry I'm sorry my
dad yeah have you ever saved a human
life I've had a decent amount of phone
calls with people that
have expressed suicide or thoughts of
hurting themselves and to be able to
work through that feeling with them is
it's pretty intense
and
and and it kind of reminds me back to
that like demi lovato point really about
why people even want to go through that
process in the first place death no
hurting themselves what doesn't you only
hurt yourself if you do too much because
you can hurt yourself without dying and
hurting yourself so really bad but the
Schindler asked another question yes and
where she I don't know who Schindler is
what do you do personally for your
health and longevity yeah it's a good
question - these are good questions
Schindler write good questions with you
don't have to write he's watching I know
I just want to write yeah I know but did
with this is television what the Christ
is wrong with you Alan hurt well who do
you personally do for your health and
longevity you know something that I do a
lot that I think is really good it's
just the simple like you know why are
you going out of the camera you know
when you when you like you know you
stand up and then you kind of like you
know you kind of just think move around
a bit like this and even this kind of
like just simple movement of your body
just unlocks it and opens it up and it
feels really great so I would say like
that is a really good for health
[Music]
so you think that if we were to start
another Facebook event that that it
wouldn't work because we've already
clicked on stream one time right I don't
know what happened with that I knew the
first time we did it we did it and it
worked we have a lot of room to go yeah
to get better at this so we'll get
better at this it's too bad no it's too
bad nobody's skyping in Skype us at
simulation series operators are standing
by
yeah Skype in simulation series
operators are standing by
all right let's see any other questions
no more no here I'll just do this what
did anybody comment and say it can't see
the stream on Facebook
all right cool we're live now on white
on Facebook are you sure yeah really
well because I just I did it from the
camera of the computer ocean lers ask
some more questions are you just doing
it from your camera Schindler has asked
do you eat healthy or take supplements
can you just put the chat in the YouTube
and not the video
let's see pop out chat yeah just do that
and when down the road we'll set it up -
yeah
good questions Schindler good questions
can you kill the page behind you so I
don't see it well I also want to keep
the I want to keep the Facebook open a
bit so I'm just gonna do this there that
looks good okay I Fernando thanks for
liking on Facebook Schindler good
questions so do you eat healthy or take
supplements you know after doing vai ohm
which is a Naveen Jane's
project I've learned that and I haven't
fully learned I'm just starting to learn
that there's no such thing as just like
one healthy food which is crazy to think
of right cuz we're taught all the time
that there is a there is like a healthy
food choice so I guess what I normally
eat is I eat like a little bit of fruit
vegetable meat a lot of water and tea
sometimes I take fish oil it's kind of
what I'm doing but do you have a
favorite rants humanist a movie it's
another good question my favourite
transhumanists the movie is Zoltan east
bond that's my favorite chance you miss
the movie
who I was just making a joke a Zoltan is
transhumanist and he is basically a
movie his life as a movie he's such a
fun guy the candidate for president that
spoke at World's Fair Nana yeah he's a
libertarian on the transhumanism
platform whereas Andrew yang who we
spoke with the other day and yang is his
name
Andrew yang for president Democratic
candidate for president 2020 all on the
ubi very smart man comes from a legal
background I understand well aware
decent good guy doesn't have your arm
you know your typical politician
personality which is you know brain-dead
and zombie-like completely full of [ __ ]
Andrew yang 2020 president of the United
States of America why not
you know what's you know what's
interesting oxygen in the water and in
the air that's that's what's interesting
how oxygen can be in the water but we
can't necessarily breathe it but we
breathe it outside that's fascinating
interesting I think Schindler has asked
another question let's see if I can get
it yeah there it is okay cool I'm gonna
share this one now all right sure no all
right there we go cool all right sir
Schindler has asked what do you think
about the immortality coffin bus yeah
yeah Schindler how do you know all these
different things who is Schindler
Schindler will you Skype us yes yeah
that's great Skype asset simulation
series please and let's get you let's
get you on will you Skype
simulation series at gmail.com
it'd be great to get Schindler to chat
with us for a bit it'd be fantastic to
do it on the fly as if like we know what
we're doing here alright you there are
you there caller Phil Donahue back in
the dead you know Phil's on you is think
so yeah you think so mmm yeah let's uh
let's do Skype the immortality coffin
bus insult hands project yeah the I
think it was the idea that my soul tan
went around in uh oh he is Schindler's
gonna call and wait a second okay great
great
we got and what's his name again
Schindler I gotta do the the double
boxes with his name see we ate we need
insurance to type in his name and where
is he calling from yeah booth this is
exciting
caller are you there Schindler's calling
I'm excited are you there are you there
caller bomb compound but don't put a cup
of bean bean bean being about um butter
bomb common good but you could pop boom
ba-ba-boom you should talk you should
take this time to talk about stuff that
we've done what we got coming up you're
right you're right we've done 170
interviews in the last seven months we
are doing all the live events that we
mentioned at the beginning of the show
and we were actually offline so nobody
actually heard oh he says I'm Rowan good
to meet you Rowan is he skyping in I
don't see him coming in yet at
simulation series oh there it is hold on
I want to answer it answer it
we jack cheese channel there it is okay
I think we got him
I think he's here all right I'd like to
see let's see if I can get him to
once you pull it up it'll be good
because I'll be able to see it at the
same time too
where is he I don't I don't hear him
hold on I mean uh okay he's out he's on
Channel seven input seven or working on
ya video not available how come your
videos not available how come I can't
hear you also why can't we hear you
mm-hmm what's the put that there you do
this reset uh-huh we just oh the
interesting huh hi incredibly gay ah now
we get the trolls on incredibly gay is a
person that just commented on YouTube
and asked or the video starting hold on
he's come asked what's the biggest
insight you've gotten from doing these
interviews that's a good question
probably the you know the
interconnectedness of all of this
information has been great also just the
sheer amount of stuff that I don't know
and the sheer kind of brilliance of all
of these different people that we've had
the pleasure of hosting on the show
that's a very good question incredibly
gay thank you for asking that's that's
amazing
yeah the name is incredibly gay
incredibly gay yeah
Luke Robert Mason has joined Luke what's
up brother thanks for joining video
starting I don't have heard been
answering questions from from Joplin
Steel Schindler incredibly gay okay
Sharon Sharon shoutout to you Luke
thanks for waving share and shout out
thanks for commenting what do you think
about patterns in nature and how do they
contribute to your views on the meaning
of life that's a great question Wow we
have another question from Luke how did
this all start Wow okay we can't keep up
with the questions fast enough now
interesting they weren't coming fast
enough really this is great thanks for
tuning in and chiming let me answer
these okay so what do you think about
patterns in nature I think patterns in
nature are absolutely fascinating also
how's that Skype call I'm calling them
back okay Ron's calling him back so yeah
I'm not answering the patterns in need
Sherriff fascinating and they tell us so
much about I think the meaning of life
they they tell us about the the the
beautiful relationship that we have with
nature and how we are not separate from
in nature we are nature we are humans on
this rock along with the whales and the
giraffes and the ants and the microbes
and everything that's on this planet and
so I love all of the fractal patterns
and I just envision other rocks orbiting
stars have these same fractal patterns I
think that there's it's difficult to
strip away my love for for Earth and
nature and how that contributes the
meaning of life so it's great question
thanks Sharon
all right hey now Luke Robert Mason how
did this all start all right you get
started good question it started with
the list of thought-provoking questions
and then the desire to get look if the
camera they're calling you in this is
alive you look at the camera yeah we'll
talk to these people yes also answer the
question yeah Dora do I shoot Alfredo's
a teammate of ours very strong teammate
thanks for tuning in Allie Allie thanks
for tuning in as well okay so look at
the camera when you have Luke's question
Alfredo thanks for tuning in Allie
thanks for tuning you go back to the
question how does all starts oh so we
have this list of questions and we
wanted to get leaders from around the
world from different industries to
answer the questions and we thought that
it would be really awesome to ask them
about artificial general intelligence
about globalization about wealth
inequality about cosmic perspective
about simulation theory about all these
tough questions to answer and so yeah
initially we got a lot of interest from
these leaders and they were like why
don't you go and answer the questions
get them answered by more people and so
what better way to do that then the
start of daily showing live event series
around it Ronnie thanks for tuning in
shout out to Ronnie Ronnie yeah Ozzie
spell it with the Y or an IO and
I huge catalyst for us at women in tech
international much love we're gonna do a
women in tech event with Ronnie as well
in September the end of the month we're
currently exploring that on the 28th of
September that's really exciting didn't
they just have one yeah well you know
we're gonna do our own women in tech of
that oh where do simulations simulations
did you tell me about this yeah I did
yeah just recently okay yeah in that
yeah
just recently yeah because it was just
yeah you sent me an email
is there an email no they've never when
we have this conversation about you know
let's put it thanks for ending it
everyone this has been great we really
appreciate you tuning in and and talking
to us on on this broadcast go ahead the
for people that are watching on Facebook
right now ask a question any question
would be a lot of fun we'd love to hear
from you too those on YouTube as well go
ahead and ask a question we'd love to
hear from you yeah that's the beauty of
propagating questions Oh incredibly gay
asked a question who are the people you
want to interview the most in the future
it's a great question
we'd love to interview Neil deGrasse
Tyson Tony Robbins Elon Musk
Mark Zuckerberg Jeff Bezos jenna jameson
Michelle Obama Barack Obama that would
be awesome
we'd love to interview Bill and Melinda
Gates Oprah Ellen DeGeneres like George
Clooney I have him excited I am
George Kalam like other people like like
Kim Jong moon Donald Trump
like Bashar al-asad like if we could
[ __ ] interview the Syrian ruler that
would be really interesting like I bet
people aren't expecting me to be talking
about all these people but because it's
just interesting to be able to sit down
and and try and dive into someone's mind
like that Vladimir Putin would be
interesting like these are the people I
would like to interview so yeah those
are the people that come to mind which
is good question incredibly gay great
question ok back here Ronnie
Ronnie's been asking questions ok if you
could have a magic wand what climate
challenge would you remove if you could
have a magic wand what climate challenge
would you remove ok I think I have to
answer this so it would be that right
now we're experiencing a increase in the
parts per million of co2 in our
atmosphere to a degree that's not yet
extremely troublesome but it's on its
way to be troublesome and the magic wand
I think what I would do with the climate
challenge and like what what climate
challenge would you remove I think maybe
the answer then would be it would maybe
be a transition to completely
sustainable sources of energy like with
the magic wand wave and you know
preferably to the most efficient sources
of an alternative energy solar wind
water nuclear fusion all these awesome
sources of alternative energy that would
be my harvesting the power of our Sun
yeah that's a good question Dyson thanks
for joining I just saw you Dyson thanks
for joining
appreciate it
Oh oh good oh oh we have questions oh
I've been missing these questions ok ok
what significant transformation do you
think will occur in Western culture
within the next 5 to 10 years
from alfredo servantes alfredo our boy
what significant transformation do you
think will occur in Western culture in
the next 5-10 years well I think one of
the big ones is that the empowerment of
women and the feminine characteristics
qualities voices energies feelings that
empathy and wisdom and nurture and and
and the mother earth the guy spirit
these these are very fascinating
thoughts and and I feel some of them
within me like really strongly and I
think it's very strange that that that
it's dead that we that we've maybe
transition to the world that we have
today because of a lot of the greed and
the corruption and stuff and hopefully I
guess transition and another
transformation I think will occur in
Western culture I think is very
interesting is that the overall idea of
what it means to be human is shifting
way faster than we've ever imagined it
was just a little bit ago that humans
were just being augmented by like trains
and planes and penicillin and stuff and
now humans are being augmented by the
smartphone and now smart glasses and now
your biometrics are being measured and
and your everything is crazy going
digital in that sense so I think that's
the next five to ten years as well
there's gonna be crazy transformation
I'm incredibly gay asks is there anyone
you've interviewed that you'd like to
interview a second time not everybody I
know I know I actually I like that
question Neru Khosla nehru Khosla I
would like to interview you a second
time Jordan Peterson I would like to
interview Jordan Peterson a second time
there's lots of other people to bina48
yeah artificial intelligence we could
interview bina another time
good question incredibly a good question
Alfredo asks what are your thoughts on
time ha well we have a video on our
playlist about thoughts on time that
people can check out time their time is
very interesting writing a book of yeah
there you go yeah what do you thoughts
on time I would have immediately came
back with well as a matter of fact I
just so happen to be writing a book
about my thoughts on time don't you know
anything about marketing and promotion
yeah I'm a little bit more Jason Silva
coming up in less than a month yeah yeah
mmm
yeah so there's a lot of thoughts on
time and that it'll be interesting to
unpack those more I think it's very
important to apply the Preta principle
to time and understand that there's only
a certain the 8020 rule
oh the proto principle oh the prat opens
8020 rule so 8020 rule so what is the
kosis so 20% of all knowledge
constitutes 80% of all the fruits that
you can get from it and 80% of all
knowledge it can only give you like 20%
of the fruit so you got to really try
and seek that 20% of knowledge that's
gonna get you a majority of the wisdom
and then also that same thing applies to
like the network effect and who you hang
out with and the neural architecture of
children they're being form into the
world that's it's a lot to unpack get
incredibly gay asks what opinion /
stance do you hold that most people
disagree with incredibly gay that's a
great question
[Music]
I'd really like asking that question on
the show - I haven't talked about this
one I I think I've maybe talked about it
once on air on the McKenzie slaughter
episode at the blockchain for social
justice but I think that the combination
of the Boston Dynamics robots with the
Palantir data fusion software and like
the Chinese sesame credit scores and
their computer vision on their
population and facial recognition I
think this is I think this is leading me
towards a very troubled vision of the
future I'm also very optimistic in many
ways but no I I don't you know that most
people disagree that I'd say that some
people actually agree with that
perspective as well so oh oh I I kind of
believe in salep systems and I think
most people disagree with solecism that
I'm the only thing that's real and
everything else is just a figment of my
imagination that I'm just in a
simulation and that I'm the only thing
that's real and that ron's in his
simulation potentially if he actually he
might just exist in mine as a figment of
mine he might not actually be real in
his own but that's a good question I
would say solipsistic a partner that you
love and you're really deep with them
looking them in their eyes all stuff and
then like maybe the simulation like
dissolves a little or like you're like
you know you're with your mom and you're
hugging your mom and like you're really
realizing that your mom's the one that
like really brought you into this world
and like maybe the simulation fades a
little or you make they don't really
bring us into the world though they just
we come through them yeah we don't
really belong to them and that's that's
important 200
dan any newborn that comes in it's the
mom is just a vehicle and she's granted
those responsibilities there but we come
through them we do not we are not of
them
yeah it's a big fractal actually of the
repetitive births I love my mom by the
way I you know I miss you love mom too
good these have been great questions
everyone oh we've been missing some
questions okay
all right Dyson always interested in
what you're talking about some of it is
over my head but always interesting
thanks for the comment Dyson I'm trying
to figure out how to make things
relatable and I'm glad that you think
that it's always interesting because
look at the camera please
that's Dyson thanks that's a strong word
always I hope that at least you know
part of it is interesting and making it
making you feel like your consciousness
is being expanded in new dimensions of
thinking and if things are you know just
feel free to comment just like this and
be like hey like you know I didn't get
that part or like make that part more
relatable and I will I will literally
make that part more relatable so please
do that it'll be a good challenge for us
so I really appreciate you saying that
Thank You Fernando hello thanks for
commenting London London what's up
thanks for joining Ronnie what is your
favorite place on earth Ronnie that's a
good question what is your favorite
place on earth
I really like my body I'm just tuning it
in my body and my mind and heart but I
also like going outside of that on earth
okay on earth so not outside of Earth I
don't know I like being like yes like ah
like I love being like maximize like
that but I also like the chill
meditation side of things as well and I
think that's been an interesting
dichotomy so when I'm like maximized I'm
doing things like skydiving or like or
like you know like I don't know running
through the woods naked you know or
having the waves of the ocean just take
me and just freaking just pummel me and
that stuff super fun
yeah I think being with really great
people is amazing as well so thank you
to everybody actually but but I also
just don't know if this is real or not
so yeah but I appreciate the effort of
everyone including myself hopefully I'm
more than a figment in their
imaginations as well are you a figment
of my imagination or am I one of yours
watch closely now that's a reference
that I don't think too many people will
get oh sorry about that
go ahead oh just think Schindler said my
Michael isn't working he's trying to fix
it so Schindler's trying to call back
here Thank You Schindler we appreciate
it
we're here standing by when you're ready
to call hey anyone on face anyone on
Facebook and YouTube right now if you
guys want to use Skype and call
simulation series at gmail.com on skype
simulation series point down so it is a
graphic yeah so you can point down right
in the middle there's a graphic right
here wait no but you got a like point
right there yeah right right thing oh I
see it's like the good work yeah all
right so so call us on skype okay
incredibly gay if you had the power to
force everyone in the world to watch one
of your interviews which interview would
it be it's interesting question these
questions are interesting guys thank you
for thank you for these questions look
at the camera Thaddeus what's up
Thaddeus thanks for thanks for how you
gonna answer the question you did not
just say hello to somebody that's coming
in daddy says audio good here Cameron
what's up
Cameron Szalai what's up brother thanks
for joining in okay all right
an incredibly gay if you had the power
to force everyone in the world to watch
one of your interviews which interview
would it be okay so that's a good
question okay what what is the answer
probably Mogao dot was really good
we talked a lot about conspicuous
consumption and how it's not the meaning
of life and we talked a lot about
happiness and how to just be happy in
the present moment look at the camera
and not and not be lost in the past or
in the future and we talked a little bit
about death and about about the
afterlife and things like that that we
don't have the answers to but that we
thought were very interesting so I
really like that one
that's a great question and I think
Jordan Peterson's interview was great
too because of the though we talked
about wealth and equality in deep detail
we talked about how to have really good
conversations in deep teetsi a detail we
talked about this competence hierarchy
and how we're basically climbing up
these genetic Fitness landscapes in a
sense so so I would I like that one as
well that's that's a good one as well to
reference um okay Ronnie said no feet it
seems to have stopped broadcasting on
Facebook oh is it is it not working
question mark
it seems to be working on our end
somebody give us a call on skype
simulation series on skype it's right
here it's right here give us a call give
us a call hopefully I play over there
just play like right it's like right
here it's right behind right there right
there okay Manoli what's up thanks for
joining us Facebook feed good for me
think status thanks for letting us know
Manoli okay awesome so good thumbs up
okay is it too late to call in no call
in Schindler call in call in pop out
that chat for a second will say call in
I am calling Schindler says he's calling
okay
we're standing by incredibly gay which
intellectuals do you think should get
more attention that's a really great
question
what's that noise with people in the
hall which intellectuals do you think
should get more attention wow that's a
good question
there are definitely for example here's
here's a good example you know you take
a youtube channel like in a nutshell
and you observe what in a nutshell is
doing and in a nutshell is making very
relatable ways of understanding complex
subjects and this is a team of people
right so these are not like these are
not a public single intellectual this is
a team of people being a public
intellectual channel and I love stuff
like that I love it it's really good
it's really strong and then in terms of
a single public intellectual
I don't I don't really know any single
public intellectuals that are not
getting enough voice right now Erica
Weinstein I think deserves a little bit
of a bigger voice I think he's got a lot
of interesting nuance multivariate
things to say but he already has like a
pretty decent voice in the sphere we're
talking about people that are babies
that have almost no voice and no
following because if that's the question
then who are the public intellectuals
that deserve that stop taking at your
ear yeah that's a good question
incredibly gay very very good questions
coming from you
Oh Nathan Nathan what's up love you and
miss you and thanks Nathan
much love much love love you miss you
too thanks for commenting and joining
greatly appreciate it let's hear a
question anyone want to call in via
Skype simulation series on skype you can
join us on the show right here and we're
waiting there's issues with schindler
answer call I'm trying to answer his
call and I'm in and it says it says busy
in a call I'm gonna hang up I'm gonna
hang up here come on we're trying to get
schindler in on that yeah yeah this is a
pain in the destiny hi destiny thanks
for tuning in we appreciate it
I've been doing a lot of circling lately
we haven't been doing yes to these
destinies chiming in yeah we have we
haven't been doing any circle recently
I'm smitten what is that is that a blush
over there I'm she's cute
okay someone's coming in what is this I
got something here here we got a speck
wait no yeah return return come on come
on come on come on yeah destiny says
nice shirt thanks destiny I appreciate
that
gotta be different in this world you
know can't have any of that same BS
I liked eccentric clothing the more
unusual your clothing is the healthier
your life is usually the more I wouldn't
say it's always true some people can go
off the rails off the walls and just do
really really really crazy [ __ ] every
single moment of their lives crazy and
then there's no real like ego controller
stability maybe in a sense but but I do
really like neither have I yeah your
destiny as I've been doing much circling
you there that's funny Schindler give us
a call on skype thanks for tuning in
everyone we really appreciate you tuning
in thank you it's it's it does mean a
lot to us to not just be here by
ourselves so we've had 40 minutes of of
people tuning in and asking great
questions so I'm very blessed and
honored to even you know we've we've
kept up with the questions that's great
that means they've been coming in at it
at a good rate incredibly gay asks who
is the most interesting person you've
interviewed slash want to interview we
already answered that um didn't we yeah
I think we answered something similar to
that yeah maybe I say that I think
someone that doesn't get enough credit
that we've interviewed as a day or se I
like a day or se personally I like his
analogies in his foresight one of the
first things that he taught me a day or
se was both number one and then he was
like number eighty or something on the
second time he was on the show was our
first one that we but but the first time
listen to these things that a day taught
us a day Oh in the first episode taught
us about how if you go and just look at
civilization and humans and you you know
if maybe if you're you're like a
one-year-old if you're like absolutely
immoral and you don't
treat anyone with respect or dignity or
anything and you're just really a cancer
on society and then you're like let's
say you're like a thirty year old you're
an adult if you are moral and righteous
and honest and and loving and caring and
passionate for Earth and colonizing
other star systems and you're just super
intelligent adayla thinks that most
people are like seven year-olds are like
six-year-olds even and that and that's
most of us and like the best-case
scenario is like people that are trying
to take better care of our earth and
each other and those people are like 12
years old or 11 so we have such a vastly
long way to go so anyway that was the
first thing and the second thing that he
taught us on the second episode with
this analogies was that your plane is
crashing as in literally we're all
humanity's in a plane and the pilots
have fallen asleep and the planes
crashing and everyone's drinking wine
and looking out the window and going
like well that's okay and there's a
couple of people going that's not okay
and those couple people going that's not
okay are the ones that are observing all
of the exponential technology that's
going on this is the artificial general
intelligence this is the wealth
inequality this is what's gonna happen
in the next couple of decades because we
haven't had the discussions that we need
this is not fear this is about foresight
I've said that a lot this is not about
fear this is about foresight look at you
go yeah I am so full of passion III I'm
actually I'm actually very low on energy
because I didn't get a chance to sleep
last night because I was just working
and I've I've been going to sleep a very
weird times around like 8 a.m. or 10
a.m. and waking up at like 4:00 p.m.
somedays and that's just a very weird
sleep schedule so to this so I stayed up
posted that stuff about Elon Musk and
the work hard thing and you get ahead
you need oh come on yeah yeah but but
I'm just gonna sleep dead
now I'm resetting so meaning that I'll
if I go to bed tonight at 10:00 p.m. or
midnight I'll actually wake up at 6 a.m.
or 8 a.m. and I'll be back on a
different grind it'll be it'll be
interesting to mess with that Schindler
still says he's fine I hope it works out
someone call us I took I tried to take
the call I call us on skype at
simulation simulation series I'm gonna
pin that comment in comment ok yay thank
you everyone really appreciate you
tuning and this has been a lot of fun
are we done I think I think we're pretty
good if we can get a Skype Oh Emma join
what's up hey try to get us on skype try
to call us on skype we'd love to do a
Skype AMA on a video conference we can
put your picture right there on the TV
and on the screen and have some fun with
it
yeah we got it we gotta practice
we gotta practice doing this yeah we do
have to keep practicing getting better
at this that's right the fact that we
only stream to Facebook today was
problematic I all we didn't yeah we
didn't like your streaming live on your
from your laptop right yeah and you
should tell them to go to youtube though
when you're there on the Facebook you
should have said hey we got a really fun
looking show on YouTube and watch us on
YouTube other than the single webcam
from your laptop here's the you know
they can't see me when I'm chiming in
from your your laptop so alright I think
it's coming to a close
let me let me get the music alright I
get the music Freddie yeah let's uh
let's just do it I'm excited to go do
thoughts on humanity let's go do that
what do you mean thoughts on humanity
we're gonna go take a JVC outside did we
is that in the is that in the schedule
for today yeah on my calendar yes so
we're gonna do an AMA and we just did
that now now it's over now you're gonna
take a camera out in the street yeah and
ask people about their thoughts on
humanity which is more exciting for me
Oh Jeff Jeff T a new commenter on
YouTube thanks Jeff regardless of
political affiliation do you see the gas
lighting happening in mainstream media
that's a that's a good question and I've
recently read about gas lighting
manipulates someone but psychological
means into questioning their own sanity
damn that is [ __ ] crazy that's what
you do hey you do that I do yes
manipulate people sometimes a gas line
yes sometimes you do serious gas like
you I've called you out on it a long
time ago oh yeah I accidentally have
done that yeah of course she did I
accidentally killed that person too back
in the mid oh yeah I'm definitely I have
so many sins this is interesting about
gas lighting though good question am i
manipulating someone by psychological
means when I say that their view on
reality isn't augmented by the lens of
science so like if your lens is
augmented towards science and you see
things in a more scientific way it's
more objective in a sense and so am I
psychologically manipulating you into
wanting to do that and does that
question your sanity so that's a good
question but but in general though I
tend to agree with you Jeff that that
there is gas lighting happening in
mainstream media FoxNews in the u.s. is
telling Democrats
telling we're installing Republicans and
Democrats suck CNN is telling Democrats
that Republicans suck and this has been
going on for a long time and it's it's
totally making people question their own
sanity I think that's a really
interesting point
yeah mainstream media has been really
shitty recently and it's too bad because
we also live in the attention economy
and that's taken away from our ability
to parse for high signal-to-noise and
and have a quantum Muskaan verse a ssin
Jeff good question
Maybelle David what's up
Maybelle David what's up thanks for
joining us you didn't get it you can you
can tell that you didn't really get much
sleep I just want to let you know that
yeah why has a professional hosting team
what's up thanks for joining us what's
up I know I catch up so I could tell
from the moment that started that I felt
that when Evan learned so thanks
everyone for joining us comment below
guys while you're here join us on skype
just Skype in simulation series call us
on skype we're trying to get someone to
call in on skype join us on skype ok
simulation series the comments been Jeff
says I agree what do we do can we regain
a civil discourse good question Jeff
what do we do is you know maybe we
propagate things like this things like
the deeply nuanced intellectual
conversations that are happening in
aspects of the intellectual dark web
maybe maybe when someone is standing
there and being very ignorant and not
knowing what they're talking about maybe
we maybe we say you know you know bless
the divinity in your soul although it is
ignorant at times and you just leave and
and maybe you leave that person out of
your life and you just turn that gene
expression off in your network and you
move on to another
two more civil discourse and more
nuanced discourse okay let's see
questions Alan hi hi Maybelle Brian
Brian ah what's up good to see you man
thanks for coach thanks for joining
thanks for chiming in Brian you should
join us on skype you're [ __ ]
hilarious it would be great if you join
us on skype simulation series Brian
calling out us on Skye he can hear you
I know he can others I want to write
reiterating not a double whammy we
should have interns that do that say
thanks for thanks for yeah good yeah
yeah I would love her for please join us
on skype we wanna it's working on our
end it wasn't working on Shindler's end
yeah why does the Skype conversation the
Skype call I couldn't instead why I
can't establish the call it says
establishing a call right now with
Schindler but he's not answering it
still says establishing with them okay
I'm gonna end it I need to I need to
update this to Brian can joined today
but thanks okay no worries
I'm gonna I'm gonna call you on skype
everyone thank you for tuning and thank
you thank you greatly appreciate it if
you guys have any questions write them
how about Brian write a funny question
he's Brian's the Brian is the science
comedian he is the science comedian did
Kevin speaking of comics there's Kevin
whittinghill watch the show I have no
idea I miss him
shout out to Kevin the partner of Eureka
comedic co-host pompous ass oh that's
not nice and this is time you know
alright let's let's call it uh but you
go take a nap before you said it
no the streets will give me energy man
at night I walk the stick and streets
and I hit the same old block everyone I
love you I love you I love you we love
you thank you very much for tuning in
thank you for all of your
thought-provoking questions this has
actually been you know what do we have
34 comments on Facebook ok shout out to
Brian mallow Maybelle Chan destiny grace
Ryan our Nathan ready Thaddeus Kia
Manolis skiathos Ron Ronnie LF Fernando
Ramirez Dyson to launch Luke Robert
Mason shout-out to you guys thanks for
chiming in and asking questions on
Facebook okay hold on I need to open up
YouTube now I need to give shout out
shout outs on YouTube now YouTube shout
outs YouTube shout outs go to Joplin
steel Schindler Schindler with all these
dope questions incredibly gay great
questions as well Sharon Sharon thanks
for your great question
Alfredo shout-out and
and last one all these Jeff T thank you
everyone for tuning in to our first AMA
we'll be back with more AMA soon baby
stay tuned let's do it
[Music]
you